in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast we have a very
special guest because once again she's
so highly requested because the first
time she was here talking about that she
lost much no tea today only tears I kid
you not like I rarely check comments but
whenever I do that video still gets
comments till this day over all the
other videos oh we hit it with the we
hit it with the hottest click mate but
like it's it's it was it's still like
interesting you know and also I think
everyone expected like it to be like a
bunch of [ __ ] talk and it was just like
no I didn't go to college I need like I
mean I did briefly yeah but like you
know not enough to lay I don't know yeah
it was interesting cuz when that video
came out some people were just there was
I think like 99% of people understood
what you were talking about but there
was that 1% of hardcore Smosh fans
they'd even see the video and they just
saw the title and their label [ __ ] this
girl she's black I had some okay so the
I'm pretty sure like by the time this
video comes out it'll like have actually
been announced about the girls and I are
doing like another side project all
that's right and like you know they put
out a teaser video and Gio was like hey
guys like post this whatever so like I
went to post it and like before I went
to post it I saw a comment and it was
from this person I don't look I don't
remember what your name is but you know
who you are there was like a comment
from this one person they were like bows
bows climbed Smosh she used Smosh and
now she's using JK news I was like
listen you stupid [ __ ] I literally left
to get a nine-to-five job because I
wanted to do a career shift and then I'm
just doing other projects with friends
well first of all what do you mean you
this is so [ __ ] dumb this is how
stupid people are what do you mean used
she was hired that was her job contacted
what are you talking about she was
employed by them used you dumb [ __ ]
she was contractually employed and got a
paycheck from them you [ __ ]
it's like and like especially with like
fan bases like that there's a for some
people not all of the fans but for some
fans there is a concept of what they
want to be true it's like a perfect
example it's like Twilight when God what
are their names the the Edward and Bella
people in their life they actually dated
but when they broke up people refused to
let it happen you know they had this
fantasy in their head of what they
wanted to happen and if that didn't
happen
they were [ __ ] pissed wait they
didn't realize they did they yeah they
actually did and then then it broke up
it's like the same [ __ ] with like Selena
Gomez and Justin Bieber people create a
fantasy of who you are and what your
life is supposed to be and when it gets
shattered like it you know they they get
mad about it so like you know maybe this
person believed like oh I was supposed
to be in Smosh not beause you know the
play it's so [ __ ] it's really weird
actually I take it back people cope with
their surroundings in different ways but
don't put that [ __ ] on me I don't have
time for it yeah I mean I I think like
the comments kind of really it really
shows how people are right so for me in
my small little bubble I always expect
people I always give people the benefit
of the doubt right like these like most
people are generally intelligent I don't
think that's the case I think what
actually happens is like when social
media came out everybody said the same
thing they say that social media is
making people stupid
I don't think social media made anybody
stupid I think social media showed just
how many stupid people there are Oh
social media and the Internet as a whole
is just a million people finding out at
once that there are people with
different opinions in them yeah you know
initially when we first when we first
got online like I am a child of the
Internet I was on neopets at [ __ ] 10
I've been playing video games for years
I am a child of the internet and I think
for a lot of y'all especially around my
age or even just 10 years ago when we
first started getting online we
gravitated towards people that had
similar interests
like if you were on LiveJournal you
joined communities of like metal bands
or like if you are on MySpace you liked
people that you know had profiles that
looked a certain way you gravitated
towards your coven and now those groups
have started to kind of dissipate they
still exist but we are all connected to
each other through like Twitter
in other mediums and so now we're seeing
these other opinions whereas you know
eight or nine years ago they weren't
always so blatantly in our face and now
they're being served to us daily and
people want to get mad about it I'm so
I'm so confused - sometimes when so for
example if they if somebody tells a
story like on an online platform right
immediately I feel like a lot of people
say the same [ __ ] specifically they
always say either either I hear it a lot
from me like I'll tell the story and
they go that's impossible and I start to
realize I started to realize like I
wonder why I wonder why it's when
somebody says something the immediate
response is that you don't believe it
and what I figured out was that a lot of
people tend to want to rationalize
things with stuff that's only within
their reality their bubble they go if I
wouldn't have done that then clearly
it's impossible right but and so like
for example like like I told this story
when I was a kid right so when I was a
kid I said like a lot of anger issues
and even till this day I you know I I
tried to manage my anger problems but
when I was a kid it was super bad like I
had to go through therapy for it and
[ __ ] and yeah that's other stuff so like
I told the story back in the day and a
couple of times because when it came up
you know I would just tell the story
about me when I was a kid I stabbed this
kid in his face when I was like eight
years old with a pencil like I stabbed
it through his mouth in the cheek
etiquette stitches I got removed from
that school and I almost got expelled
from that Elementary School and so on
and so I read a comment recently where
somebody was like you know David thinks
he's such a [ __ ] thug he's talking
about so he stabbed people I was a hole
on a second I told that story when I was
eight years old
I was and it's also and it's not to brag
it's to show how far you come exactly
you could have been versus who you were
in my mind I'm like why did you think
that was a story or number when I was
bragging and number number two did you
not remember the part I was eight years
old
yeah how the [ __ ] was I a thug I was a
dude exactly like it sweetie David it's
so weird you know I'm like what story
did I tell that made you feel that way
right and so what happens is and when I
start to realize - especially with
people they go oh when I was a kid I
wouldn't have done that well I'm sorry
that you were such a little [ __ ]
alright when I was a kid I got bullied a
lot right so because I was bullied a lot
but also at the same time I had a father
who was very tough and he told me that
when you go to the school number one
I wasn't born here I was an immigrant so
oh I already had a disadvantage like
people already picking on me so my dad
always told me listen you're never
allowed to put your hands on people
first but if they ever touch you or if
they ever do something to you I give you
full rein to do whatever you want
protect yourself and so for me when I
was a kid I always made it a point to
say hey you can try and bully me as much
as you want but I will be that bully kid
but I'll be the most difficult one ever
you know so you might have to think
twice before you bully somebody like me
right there mind you like I understand
why people bold me I was the easy target
I want to bully myself back in time and
I saw myself I would have taken my own
lunch money but and so like I I had to
really sit there and thinking it's like
I wonder why this is such a far-fetched
story for people to believe why is this
so far-fetched that you would hear a
Korean dude that grew up with a bunch of
black people why is that so far-fetched
why is it so far-fetched that a Korean
guy likes R&B and hip-hop and that he
that he does that without trying to be
quote unquote black why is this such a
hard idea for people to wrap their head
around and I realize is because once
again it's not within what they believe
is to be true because it's not within
that rationale it's automatically a lie
and I like how close-minded are these
human beings like it's kind of sad dude
you know I think I think you're touching
on a really good point of like sitting
that I've always thought about and it's
the bubble it's the bubble that we all
kind of live in and I think a really
good example of this are like some
youtubers like you know like not like
you and like a lot of like JK and stuff
and I think that's why I gravitate so
much to you guys because you guys see
the bigger picture but you know as I
came in as I came into the industry I
met a lot of people that were severely
depressed yeah a lot of really depressed
youtubers like you know I'd like people
that have been in the game for a minute
and you know they they had their peak
and they felt like they might have like
fallen off or they didn't keep up with
that momentum you know and these people
they live in their own bubble where they
compare themselves to other things in
that bubble everyday and and they wonder
why they [ __ ] hate themselves so much
and they feel like they're not being
successful you need to look outside of
the bubble like you need to look far
outside of the bubble like I kind of
think of it I feel like I feel like I'm
not explaining it that well but like my
I guess the best way to explain it is
like when I grew up I was a [ __ ]
loser
like total [ __ ] loser named Winston
three schools like in high school
actually I think I went to four
different high school yeah yeah four
different ones complete [ __ ] loser
nobody likes me my hometown like I I was
basically nothing like right up until 25
and somehow I get plucked out of my
bubble that I couldn't see out of and I
get thrown into a much bigger bubble
which is LA which is this new industry
and from somebody that came from
literally nothing this micro bubble to
being in this bigger like bubble
everything looks huge to me I I can see
outside of the bubble I can see the
edges of the bubble I can see everything
I'm like holy [ __ ] I want to keep
exploring and I'm so happy about it but
some people they just stay in this
little tiny miserable world and they
don't realize there are other bubbles
you can travel to you can go to bigger
bubbles you can see other experiences
and they're they're trapped and like you
you don't you don't have to be trapped
there
yeah and it's it's it's I always told
you know Joe also mentioned this to work
I think how was it Joe was a Geo but we
were we were talking about this where I
I said one of the biggest blessings of
my life or probably the smartest thing I
think I've ever did was travel because
prior to me traveling I had no
inclination to do it I didn't want to
yeah I didn't care about what was
outside of my little comfort zone right
and so once a Mariola asked me once she
goes how come you never want to go to
Europe I was like I don't want to go to
Europe speak because they speak English
and she goes what do you mean he's good
it's too easy for me I want to travel to
learn something new and I want to
challenge myself like I want to be in an
uncomfortable situation because I feel
like I need that as a human being cuz it
reminds me if for me when I was a kid
how I didn't want to travel because I
was always scared of how uncomfortable
uncomfortable it would be me not knowing
the language not me not knowing the food
and not knowing anybody there because I
always stuck in places where I knew
somebody because it just made me feel
comforted and if I if I broke out of
that space I got I was [ __ ]
frightened I mean I never openly
admitted it to anybody at the time when
I was younger but a lot of my friends
who did travel I was just like oh why
would you want to travel that's so
stupid yeah and I would project that
negativity because that's the stuff that
I was scared about yeah I was scared and
so it's a comfort zone yeah like and you
try to make somebody else feel bad about
doing the stuff that they want to do
because you
want them to feel as bad as you do
because if they start to go above you
then you start to feel this distance and
I always see this in a lot of friends
too where recently I had a conversation
with a people with a younger guy he and
he was telling me about somebody that's
always around him and we were around him
too and I kind of wanted to warn him
about this guy's behavior specifically
because he's somebody who number one the
guy that he's around is a very talented
guy very likable super funny like the
guy a lot but the reason why I wanted to
warn him about him was because he's also
the type of person he's only happy and
joking when you are in the same
situation that he's in yeah the moment
he'd starts doing better the other guy
he makes like slight jokes about it
right he was like oh I guess you think
you're so much better than me oh I guess
this this and that
oh who cares oh your life must be so
tough and he does it in guys of joking
but he's really what he's really saying
is that I don't like it that you're
doing better than me and if you move
past me you and I can't be friends and
you know what so I have only recently
like in I would say less than the past
year decided to get the [ __ ] rid of all
of those people because I was such a
depressed and negative person I
surrounded myself with other depressed
and negative people because we were all
miserable together yeah and then when I
started doing a little bit better these
some of these people they would do
anything to either make me feel bad or
literally go out of their way to pull me
down literally like commenting [ __ ] on
my Instagram and these were like my
friends and like sending [ __ ] to like
fans and stuff and it was like oh it's
just a joke and it's like it's not a
joke it's I it might be a joke but you
know what I don't like your jokes
anymore
your jokes are hurting me and I don't
want to I don't want to wake up at 9
a.m. and have you ruin my day from the
beginning
you're a toxic person and I don't want
to play I don't want to play the lottery
with you every day to see or every week
to see when you're gonna [ __ ] up my day
because you can there's a look because
those jokes have truth in it you know
and all jokes have a little truth in it
and so you know when somebody says when
they go out of their way to do that you
already know they're trying to make you
feel bad about something so when I first
started doing YouTube back in the day
and mind you I didn't know what YouTube
entailed right you know I kind of just
go about my day and do whatever like
even till this day I'm not balling out
of my mind and I sure as [ __ ] don't show
it I Drive a [ __ ] Honda Ellen
for crying out loud you know like I'm
just chilling just being myself
and she's oh when I went back and we you
know we got together with some of the
old homies but there was this one
[ __ ] guy that irritated me so the
first [ __ ] so the first year that I
went back when he made these comments I
kind of just brushed it off my shoulder
so it would be some [ __ ] like Oh mr. mr.
popular is back mr. cool guys back or
whatever you know and I'm kind of like
laughing it off or whatever but as you
get older you just your threshold for
[ __ ] gets really really small so we
were kind of at this you know
gathering so whenever I come back in
town like I was at the homies up and
then it's got me the same [ __ ]
comment he goes oh he goes oh what's up
cool guys like you know how's it like
being rich and living out in LA and I
took him aside I was like what the [ __ ]
is your problem
you know what do you mean and I was like
bro number one you're not a child and
I'm not a child every time I come around
you got some [ __ ] to say so what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is it that you want
to say I would just imagine you'd be
like I don't want to chew ammount in
front of my friends you know so I just
kind of took them aside I was like yo
what the [ __ ] is your problem because
I'm just joking I was like see I already
knew right off the bat you're you were
gonna say you were just joking because
that's what everybody [ __ ] says they
say they're just joking but every time I
come and you save that type of [ __ ] but
it always has like this weird [ __ ]
connotation to it so if you're joking I
don't [ __ ] like it so the next time I
come around you make that [ __ ] joke
that you're not gonna talk yeah and it
was like we're supposed to be friends
right I was like whenever you so he just
got at that point he just got a new job
when you got a new job
I [ __ ] congratulated you I said yo
Congrats on everything blah blah blah
blah no joke no underlying no bitterness
no nothing no nice that's it right but
when something good happens to me you
always got to make you always try to
make this joke and try to make me feel
bad about it so so what the [ __ ] your
problem you know and yeah to be honest
with you if he was a really good friend
after that conversation never hit me
back up he didn't even even come to the
circle anymore yeah and that's and you
know what that's fine
like and I and I i I'm so firm on like
and I'm a person that is just going
through this and I try I try so hard to
you know use my platform now because
like you know I'm working full time and
[ __ ] yeah I tried to using my platform
to how do I say this
I really hope in the next 10 years
that I will be where I want to be you
know and where I'm gonna be is that
[ __ ] top bit and so often we hear
stories of people that are already there
and you're like yeah sure this is
inspiring this is great but you don't
really relate to them so you know anyone
that like watches my [ __ ] I want them to
walk with me I want to pull everyone up
with me I want them to see me on the cut
them up I want them to walk with me and
then we all make it to the top and two
of the most important things that I can
already say that I've learned that we
talked on today is a think outside of
your own bubble get outside of your
comfort zone like we as humans we we
underestimate ourselves not realizing
that we adapt when you throw us in the
water
we will swim and if you don't think that
you can't swim [ __ ] think again man
because you will you know like we are so
adaptable you know so think outside of
your bubble and get rid of toxic people
like it will change your [ __ ] life
like there's a couple of things I've
changed in the past year and I would say
that like those are two of the hardest
hitting things that have like changed my
life entirely and I was so scared to get
rid of people that I thought I was close
to but you know sometimes you have like
sometimes you have people that are there
for you for many many years and after a
while it just doesn't work out it's time
to change and it's I'm pretty sure that
move was hard too I mean I think a lot
of people call me [ __ ] cold-blooded
because I tend to be very candid and
very straightforward right yeah and the
reason why is I actually got this from
my mom my moms like that and I I always
look at her because number one I always
wondered well how can you do that so
easily and the reason why is because
when you get older you just don't give a
[ __ ] I got I got only so many [ __ ] to
give I don't want to give it to
everybody right I mean we could give
little [ __ ] like you know this little
bit as many [ __ ] to give I have less
and less and so I need to eradicate some
of the things that cost a [ __ ]
I'm telling you see you know what I'm
talking about right so so you know
summers coming around right now right
it's wedding season yes there's a lot of
people who are getting married and this
is the weirdest part for me so people
already know number one I don't really
like weddings that much
I really don't like I'm not a wooden the
[ __ ] is that is that hot yo straight up
I thought that [ __ ] was a bottle of wine
I like this [ __ ] real is it okay I
thought that she was mad Rachel for a
second she's like dave is Korean he's
not Japanese oh [ __ ] I know this is
let's go get enjoy yourself are you
gonna judge me every time I need a drink
no I'm not gonna judge you and if you
see me on Thrillist I drink all the
[ __ ] time it's just kind of wild that
you had it in your bag gonna ask you
when I walked through that David I need
you to warm this up that [ __ ] up that's
so [ __ ] funny oh look at that look at
her go you know what this is what we
call accepting somebody for who they are
a drunkard yo [ __ ] just has a bottle of
sake are you a traveling Samurai at this
point and where are the treats at you
know your girl likes a little sip yo see
I like a little one to marry hey yo so
check this out nobody nobody in JK
drinks yes they do David I was just with
them unlike you and Paige no but check
this out
they don't really drink though oh except
I don't even know like Nicky drinks no
no Tim Tim dreams yeah TIFF drinks every
night but she doesn't drink Oh No TIFF
was in Vegas TIFF was like I just want
to keep a little buzz going
it was my favorite that's what I call
Downey tip dude it was Tim was so down
to ride okay so no tell me this wasn't
[ __ ] cute so Gina and I shared a room
sorry you know that's also we [ __ ] up
because like we sat down and we were
like pain we just we just went right
into it though what the [ __ ] we went
deep ro fast we did you know what girls
have a really amazing ability to do that
don't like I feel like for me I [ __ ]
love Girl Talk the most because girls
tend to they just open up themselves a
lot more like they have they show their
[ __ ] wounds with guys a there's like
a lot of Hoops that you have to go
through right so you have to go in and
out and finally a dude will open
but girls I always love Girl Talk
because girls oh they got the
[ __ ] teeth it would be because
we hold stuff in because y'all think
we're [ __ ] crazy so then we have to
like talk about it amongst each other
see I wish see I'm telling you one when
I get old enough I'm just gonna get a
sex change I'm gonna chop my dick off
get a [ __ ] and I'm gonna go to a
bathhouse with ladies I just start
talking what's up ladies like I'm a
woman now in the bathhouse we don't talk
man we in Japan like I feel like a lot
of the girls are booked so typically in
like on sends you don't really speak a
lot like you just stay real quiet but
then the hotel that we were at the owns
and everybody was talking specifically
there was a bunch of Chinese tourists
though just yapping it up I was like let
me save it for the so I had an uber it
up here yeah I told you it was an hour
and 15 minute ride yeah I know right but
it was a I got in and you know how
sometimes you have a talkative driver no
I was like I have like a trick to it at
this point if I have a long ride be nice
but don't talk until the last like 10
minutes you know yeah and he starts
talking to me immediately
like immediately and like 15 and like I
keep trying to like kind of in the
conversation and like 15 minutes and I'm
thinking like I need to save my energy
for camera man I need to see and he just
like kept talking and then and then he
finally said I just started driving for
Hoover two weeks ago and I was like oh
great so that this means that he's he
thinks he's got to get the good rating
and he wants talked to me the whole time
and deaded it and so like after like 30
minutes like we were driving like
through the Hollywood Hills and I was
like oh man we gotta go this way I was
like well I guess we're gonna have to
look at houses cuz I thought that this
was gonna be like really low energy and
I was so annoyed by this man and then it
felt like we were practically married we
were like look at that one yo the best
liberal drivers I [ __ ] you now are
[ __ ] immigrant Asian people because
number one it's just a job they don't
give a [ __ ] and number two they will
never talk to you cuz they can't speak
English what I've learned and I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] love it when I see if I look at
my
driver and it says his name is Zhang
Xiao Jing Chou I'm like [ __ ] yes because
this [ __ ] is not gonna give a
[ __ ] about traffic laws he's gonna get
me there faster than on time and number
three he ain't gonna say [ __ ] throughout
the ride I [ __ ] love it - maybe
sometimes it might smell like herbs but
I kid you not it's like the best like I
get excited when I see the foreign words
on there it's don't you're so funny it's
the best I kept out when I have like a
driver and there's like um and there's
like a rug on the on the seat and they
have like random textures of cloth like
draped over everything I'm like Dawg
this does not match your office one time
I had I had this uber driver and I
actually put it on my instance tour I
[ __ ] [ __ ] you not I think most people
would have given this guy a one star but
this [ __ ] was on something so he
picks me up I kid you [ __ ] not it was
on my insta story I gotta go look that
[ __ ] up but he had like [ __ ] under
glows and lights everywhere neon lights
everywhere on the inside he was blasting
techno music and on the freeway he had
all the [ __ ] windows rolled and I
said I was like you like zoom in sit in
the back I was like dude this is either
gonna be the fastest ride in my life
where I'm gonna be dead David's like no
I'm cold yeah I love bass neck like that
right if I asked him to [ __ ] roll the
windows I think he would've told me to
[ __ ] off oh my gosh but I [ __ ] love
will rise man like it's it's it's one of
those things - like if anybody asked me
to pick him up the airport I immediately
hate them I'm like I [ __ ] hate you
there's ubermann if you could afford
that plane ticket you could afford it
over I don't know it's pretty expensive
I'm gonna and I'm getting better with my
money like these days so I'm very
conscious of stuff like that like twenty
dollars is not a drop in the bucket
anymore but see for me if I pick
somebody up right let's say like
somebody picks me up I would buy them a
meal anyways so it would still cost me
like 20-something bucks either way so I
might as well just spend that on over
and not inconvenience somebody that's
true but also it's a test for what the
friendship doesn't [ __ ] that friendship
I must say [ __ ] that friendship I'm
saying it is [ __ ] that friendship
because you're trying to
Airport uuugh did you get the [ __ ] outta
here I bet you would you know what if
you asked me to pick you up I would too
but I would [ __ ] hate you for it Wow
David I would pleasantly pick you up and
sit back whatever do your feet off right
now Dora you know what I'm coming when I
fly out for another thriller show guess
who I'm calling it hey dude I'm still
look I told him the other day I was like
I was like we need to do something with
David just so we can bring his blackness
out ha ha like it's gonna happen I'm
gonna legit if you if you I'm a beat
coming back to LAX and I'm calling you
up like blows remember when you said you
gonna pick me up well guess what [ __ ]
is a Sunday and it's high traffic now
we're hanging it up right there David
you know I need at least 7 hours 7 days
notice oh no no no no we're friends 7
days notice
I mean ok look uber aside though
otherwise Airport is like an old-school
trick that's like it would would
somebody pick here from the airport how
close I was legit I said you know I
would pick you up but I guarantee you
I'd be cursing you out on the way like
as I get that I curse you I'm cursing
you out before you're there and on the
way back you would have to hear me
complain all the way back you know i'ma
say this I'm gonna say this look y'all
you know David David's got a good heart
because we barely knew each other I
didn't have your number we had never
talked outside of JK I think being shot
together like two or three times and
like one day I damned David I was like
hey man I need a favorite this dude hits
me back in five minutes he's like yeah
what you need here's my number let me
know only Oh [ __ ] my body in text me
for like two weeks I got this [ __ ] so
she's cooking cuz like she asked me for
a [ __ ] favor she just ghost is out
I'm like she's probably dead you [ __ ]
know why I thought you died it I was
like I'm dead I literally only use
Twitter on my computer I do not have the
app anymore I'm tired of it and I know
you are too because I see you yelling at
people 24/7 like what I might get on
like it'll be like one new tweet from
David so [ __ ] you my [ __ ] Twitter
like I I decided to only write like
stupid [ __ ] but not
right stupid [ __ ] back to people anymore
and the reason why is because I kind of
I kind of get caught up in it not angry
but I enjoy it too much like I try at a
certain point I dislike the person so
much I try to make them as mad as
possible so now I'm like okay well now
I'm because just being the troll so is
it started develop a really bad habit
where somebody let's say somebody to
write some stupid [ __ ] they'll be like
David [ __ ] you you're not funny then
I'll just write something else like I'll
look at their profile see what they're
doing I'm like cool or you're [ __ ]
white trash and your mom never loved you
and then they'll come at they'll say
some other [ __ ] other that's funny how
can you talk with my dick in your
[ __ ] mouth
like I would you say whatever I can by
Childish he's not even great comebacks
but it makes him so [ __ ] mad you know
I think this is okay if I can offer a
possible explanation let me just get
there you go get your thoughts going now
if I can offer at my own like what I
think it may be and then maybe we can
come up with a solution on how to like
help trolls in a healthy way
so you know how sometimes people like
leave a comment and it's so [ __ ]
angry you've never even seen this
person's name before they don't know you
it's just buck David he's stupid [ __ ]
you know blah blah blah you know umm I
wonder and just here's one theory if
like maybe we remind them of somebody
they know or we have tendencies that are
like someone that they know or maybe we
said something or have an opinion like
similar to somebody that upset them hurt
them or they don't like because where
are these feelings coming from like
sometimes these are some very strong
words you know and I can't help but
think that maybe some action or
something is vaguely reminiscent of
something from their past that upset
them see you have what you have
something called empathy oh yeah a lot
of empathy Oh oh my god David I am I'm
like I'm so empathic that it that it's
almost a problem sometimes if you ever
get second hand embarrassment absolutely
not see that so second hand
embarrassment is a sign of empathy like
empathy for some people is so strong
sometimes that you can't you like you
feel that you know you feel that in them
and it bleeds into other things
Wow and so like I I think that this
those feelings are too strong for you to
hate me from a 30 minute video and
that's something that I realized and it
helped me take things less personally
you know and so I think that sometimes
when these people leave these comments
and say these things it's a way to rise
above the person that they're relating
you to see you know what that's a grown
up [ __ ] and how much and I'm a [ __ ]
child that's not what I think what I
think is like okay so this person wrote
the [ __ ] and this person actually thinks
that this comment is funny and arguably
it's not funny you sir should not have
friends and so for me I try to figure
out why this person's life is bad not to
empathize with them but to laugh at them
inside is that empathy because I think
that's oh my god this person's [ __ ]
dog died yesterday very well deserved
stupid son-of-a-bitch
I hope your dog [ __ ] bit your balls
off before it choked on it you stupid
[ __ ] and then I go to sleep and I go
to church on Sunday you know I think
what I think is interesting is that you
know especially considering you said
that you came from a place of anger and
pain now I also came from a place of
anger and pain if we were not where we
are right now we might be those trolls
on the internet that are venting their
frustration to people because they're
having a bad boy absolutely not I would
just be on a stand-up comedy stage doing
it instead no but I'm saying if you had
taken a less positive path you know I
get your deputies [ __ ] out of you all
right get your stupid [ __ ] empathy
[ __ ] out of here and this is what I
would used to say that I would be that
person you know I wish I knew you liked
the drink because I would have stocked
up like a [ __ ] little like you
know like what's your [ __ ] like what do
you like to drink I'm sucking I dude I I
personally I love warm sake and so like
I was like oh this'll be room
temperature like you I didn't know cuz
it see it's also boiling in here so I'll
just leave this bottle right now no you
like drinking if you oh my god stocked
up cuz I'm you know we should have gone
for it for the second episode I'm a
Korean dude of course I like drink
you know after we end this episode
there's a bad mo right around the corner
my god David our Ewok we're gonna watch
the bad moment again drinking we're to
come right back I [ __ ] you not not the
best part - is that it like like this
second episode it's like a veggie
wondering how we got to this place we
talked about something going on you
don't wanna cancel on me
we have the most pathetic [ __ ] in the
world in me a stone cold I don't like I
do have empathy but I also have that
other side where I just choose not to
give a [ __ ] about somebody there's so
many people that I would have to be
empathetic towards and that would be the
more christ-like thing for me to do but
I'll tell you something man I'll tell
you Christ in me is to live look I got
all these like old Christian songs in me
but the problem with that is that oh
it's just so hard to be a Christian
sometimes I'm telling you it is so
[ __ ] difficult even as I say [ __ ]
I know I'm not supposed to say it but it
is hard and matter that's why I go to
church on Sundays to refresh me because
I feel like if I didn't go to church I
guarantee you I'd be 10 times worse as a
person well I mean you know what okay so
I am not religious but I was raised
Christian I was raised very Christian
and for like a myriad of reasons I not
only will never be a Christian but the
thought of Christianity angers me
however my grandma was a UH sure at a
church for 40 years even as a retiree
she cleans the church every Sunday she
goes in because she is out here [ __ ]
hitting the board for the Lord okay
she really okay and my mother is such
she's so religious she doesn't curse and
you know for the longest time I never
cursed around her and like when I
finally rebelled at like 26 I was like
you know what had 26 [ __ ] that's
hella late I was like I and I know I was
so respectful I never cursed around my
mother but although I am NOT Christian
and I do not foresee myself becoming a
Christian I was raised with very
Christian morals and I'm so incredibly
thankful for that because I'm a loose
cannon with like a compass that's like
go north go no yeah
you know I will say this like I do it's
funny because a lot of the people that I
vibe with they're they're not Christian
but they grew up in a Christian
household so they have a lot of those
you know the positive moral lessons that
they've got from growing up in a
Christian Church or a Christian
community that kind of seeped into who
they are right which is really good so
even for me like for as a kid let's say
my kid chooses not to be a Christian
when he's older um that's your choice
but I think I am gonna put them at a
church as a kid because I think a lot of
the stuff that I learned just just
morally wise aside from like you know
we're not gonna get into all the deep
dark [ __ ] parts of like you know
Christianity or whatever yeah but just
for the you know just like loved your
neighbor you know choose love over hate
all this type of stuff like I wouldn't
want them to at least have that
foundation absolutely you know and I
when the way I grew up I gravitated
towards like the emo and the middle kids
and stuff and I dealt with a lot of
people that were like hail Satan like
you know just to be edgy and [ __ ] like
that and and I also was friends with
some kids I thought that they were like
anarchists and stuff like I grew up
around I mean I gravitated toward some
really like these are black kids are
white kids white kids black friends if
there are any black folks out there that
want to accept me there's a lot of like
this that won't accept you yes there are
I grew up around all these kids and like
there was a point where like they were
all like baby where I was like okay
let's take a step back from this because
you know it is ambitious to think that
people are people have enough of a moral
compass or they are smart enough to know
right from wrong yeah you know they
don't they [ __ ] don't they need a
code of conduct and with Christianity
like I don't know what's gonna happen
when we all die but with Christianity
there's a code of conduct and then
there's a reward or a punishment yeah
and that is what human beings need know
if we did not have the concept of
religion so many people would run
rampant because there was no threat of
impending doom if they did bad things I
absolutely believe that religion is
necessary to keep people from going
[ __ ] insane
or like
in sensing government so I know a lot of
people who who think that having a
government is just it's just ridiculous
that people can figure it out no and
you're you're living once again in your
own bubble of thinking everyone's as
smart as you because you may be very
smart you may be have a fantastic moral
compass but you're forgetting about the
other people yeah I feel like like I
understand why people don't feel like
they should be governed for specific
things right like I completely
understand that the one thing that that
just deters me from that is the fact
that I think if we are truly just
animals then we're really based on
survival right and people will do
whatever they can to survive but if
there's no rules within that they can do
whatever they want to get to that point
of survival so and I feel like that's
some of the deepest like darkest [ __ ]
that people would do and then there
aren't rules or a code of conduct I mean
who's to say what's bad or good you know
like it's just it's very it's kind of a
scary thought for me I mean it really is
and like it once again goes to you know
you and I are people who have clearly
said that we can think outside of you
know our moral code of conduct our
bubble our comfort zone but we cannot
imagine the depths of people that are in
their darkest place we can't imagine
that and I mean how interesting is it is
that there is government and there is
religion or there's their parents that
they don't want to disappoint that are
keeping them from unleashing that really
dark side of them yeah you know and then
or sometimes it's goals aspirations a
job like I and you know what's
interesting I'm actually almost
terrified of people to have nothing to
live for if I feel like you hate your
job you hate your life you're like
single depressed whatever I like I'll
help you like best as I can but if I
feel like there's animosity towards me
or something dark I'm a little scared
because I know I know
I like how dangerous I was to myself and
others when I was in a dark place
yeah you know like like you know I I i
yeah let me tell you this some when I
was in a Riverside I was in a dorm
there was this one kid he actually got
removed to school he got arrested
because of a bomb that he was like
trying to make in his room yeah so check
this [ __ ] out I remember this [ __ ]
asian kid the kid was [ __ ] weird so
the the first like week or so or it was
like early on when we first
the Riverside I [ __ ] you [ __ ] not
this dude had like dead rabbits in his
room and so this fool brought a pellet
gun on to school so he could hunt
rabbits and cook and eat him and I was
like well first of all [ __ ]
where did you grow up you're Asian this
is a little weird he grew up in like the
LA area so I was like you didn't grow up
on a farm or some [ __ ] so this is very
odd right so his roommate apparently
contacted the authorities because he
found him trying to make like bomb kids
in in him in his closet like the like
the [ __ ] like being grits I don't know
what I'm [ __ ] were exactly yeah but
he got taken away but check this [ __ ]
out I was the nicest to him just in case
was gonna take everybody out I swear to
God like if he was gonna blow people up
there would have been a smiley face on
my door that was said you're cool you're
the best guy in the [ __ ] world I by
befriended the [ __ ] out of that weirdo
but also also I mean and like not even
from like a survival instinct but
because of the like the very empathic
thing because I've been in such a dark
place before and I know like how much
hurts how much you can't really feel
like you can't control it how deep that
spiral goes if I see somebody that's in
that position and I'm around them
constantly I will be very kind to them
because you never know when they're
gonna kill people no conversation you
know like it almost like if big thing
about it if they're spiraling downwards
and you put a break in that spiral with
a conversation or a [ __ ] joke or
something
you you really are healthy can I say
this though oh my god I tried and that
[ __ ] had no sense of humor all I
had to do was come in and just be like
hey man how you doing and he would look
at me like a idiot and he would just
walk by but I was like hey at least I'm
the one that said hi to him
[ __ ] and also another thing is
is it sometimes it's okay that's weak
that's a little odd it's up he was he
was he was he was he was out there like
he just didn't he was just kind of zoned
out all the time and I I didn't think
that he was gonna blow anybody up but I
felt like he might stab a couple of
people I didn't think he was gonna blow
anybody like he was just gonna get on
his knees start sucking digging a man if
he did that we would have been best
friends no but
not that weird that's normal now he's
he's he's good he was odd man like he
was just a weird kid and I kid you know
I kinda let them like you just look like
a skinny version of me why are you so
weird dude there's not that many Asian
people on this floor good you know what
though I am I
I feel like I was not that weird but I
was very weird I was and I would have
been nice to you every day I would have
been that break in your spiral down I've
been like hey what's up Bose and then
you would look at me but shut the [ __ ]
up fat boy no no all right man that's
cool I'm still do would you have thank
you [ __ ] I was I was really chubby but I
was very charming I was a chubby
charming man dude I was wait did you
ever see that Instagram post I did of
what I look like when I was younger yeah
she was crazy
oh my god you look like a white girl
like I was like what the [ __ ] were you
doing dude like what kind of people did
you hang out with
dude yes all white people that's [ __ ]
crazy all white people I was David I'm
mixed black people did not want me they
were like oh she's not black enough
I had no coven really really that's
[ __ ] wild I talked about this on
Tim's my cows sounds like you don't
listen
uh-huh let me tell you something real
quick I literally texted a to four times
I was like hey David here's the link to
Tim SWAT guys know you [ __ ] live you
trying to [ __ ] make me look bad on
this podcast and I'll tell you this the
reason why I don't watch that stuff is
cuz I wanted to ask you the same thing
so you could bring it back up on you I
dude I like I talked about this before
and I thought it was interesting how
like Tim and Nicki and you know everyone
they were they're from California
originally so I think they understand
how much [ __ ] racism no we don't I
mean you absolutely don't so I like I
mentioned this too before it's um when I
was starting youtube there's a lot of
kids who would talk about yo like you
know what's it like being Asian that
does this isn't that I'm like where the
[ __ ] do you live do it like what like
[ __ ] why people just come up and
pants you and go home and it and I was
like the [ __ ] do you it but they they
would literally experience [ __ ] like
that and I'm like oh it's cuz I live in
California I live in Cali I live West
Coast baby like there's a lot of Asian
people that run [ __ ] over here too yeah
you know even the thought of like an
Asian thug makes people laugh in certain
parts like what do you mean Asians those
aren't you guys all [ __ ] like
whatever [ __ ] pencil pushers and
[ __ ] number crunchers it's like cool
why don't you say that to a bunch of
asian boys out in Long Beach and see
what's up
you know so it's like oh oh so these
people do exist like there's like still
some hardcore racism out there yeah cuz
like if you came up to somebody let's
say I'll be it in a very gangster ass
neighborhood and there was a bunch of
Asian thugs and you said what's up Ching
you might get a bullet in the [ __ ]
train oh I know oh my god dude that like
you know what else people love to say
[ __ ] like that online and they would
never course no oh never never oh
absolutely not never yeah I I was like I
was trying to think like there was so
much [ __ ] that I didn't even talk about
on his podcast just like like oh my God
look so much races that [ __ ] and I think
what some people found the most was
surprising was it my first very racist
experience was with black girls
oh me too oh really
not I guess blatantly racist because
well this girl got kicked out of school
for this [ __ ] though because she called
me a [ __ ] and I never had anybody call
me a [ __ ] except for a black girl and
so I was I mentioned this too when I was
a this story when I when I did [ __ ] it
was like on a panel
yeah and they I actually told him like
I've never heard somebody call me a [ __ ]
a white person call me [ __ ]
it was actually a black girl that did at
my school when I was walking home and I
don't know what the [ __ ] she was having
a bad day or something but she said
watch where you're going you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I thought yeah and she called
me a [ __ ] and and cook and she's a GU
kitchen I never heard these terms before
like [ __ ] I was like the [ __ ] is good
and the only thing I thought was does
she know Korean cuz [ __ ] means soup and
Korean call me a good and I and I had
acid like yo [ __ ] is a racist [ __ ] and
of course I was like yo what the [ __ ]
but she got pulled aside cuz one of the
the teachers heard her say like a couple
of racial slurs they took her aside I
guess she was like one of the trouble
kids in school but she got kicked out
after that like the last straw so I was
like you know the first time somebody
called me a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] was was a
black girl really yeah dude that's I
mean I they they didn't really they
don't really call me names there's more
so that I was just uh I went to an
all-black Church and I was the the
lightest person
and I was the lightest person in the
entire congregation like the yeah I
stood out like a sore thumb but it's
just because my dad is my dad is like
white and native and so in my mom's
black so I just I just looked different
so I was very easy to say for them to
say oh you're not like us you know
church yeah that's very odd okay Christ
like yeah I mean it got arm it got very
bad and they were they started at first
they started bullying and then they
started hitting me they hit you hmm like
well punch you in the face you know what
mad cuz you had a nice straight hair
that's why we gotta pay for this [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was it was it was really bad
like it's like it's such a it was such
like a traumatizing event for me I'm
gonna tell you this story I feel like I
shouldn't even I feel like I just go
ahead oh damn one of us are crying David
thank you crash yell everybody cries I'm
gonna hide now and I look Oprah's table
every day books like this wait until he
strikes me okay
so it's gonna seem really silly but like
basically I was going through months of
mental and physical abuse by like the
same like group of girls yeah like just
the same group of girls and for
literally no reason other than probably
that I was light-skinned and my mom's an
author so like I was well I'm like
fairly like well-spoken you know and I
was just different and and so like one
day I was forced to go to this sleepover
at the church it was like a lock-in and
I didn't want to go because I didn't
have any friends and I kept telling my
parents like my mom my grandma like I
don't want to go I don't want to go
don't make me go please don't make me go
they made me go anyways and um it was
nobody talked to me the whole night I
was basically by myself and at one point
I saw some boys playing video games and
I've been playing video games cuz I was
a really lonely kid so I walked over and
I went to play video games with them and
I guess some of the girls had a crush on
some of the boys and they didn't like
that I went over and talked to them in
their eyes they're like oh look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] but I'm like ten you know
I'm not even ten I'm like seven you know
but it's just you guys are playing video
games I play that game at home I want to
play with you so I start playing with
the boys and I'm pretty good at this
game you look exactly there's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] this gets [ __ ] weird right
and this I'm also telling you why I'm
not religious yeah so uh so we so we go
like everyone like I played video games
with them I don't remember that much I
was really young and then we all go to
bed we have this like sleeping like
sleeping things or whatever yeah um and
then like I wake up at like early in the
morning and it's dark everybody's asleep
and I have this stuff like all over me
and I touch it and I thought that it was
blood and like I'm like seven you know
and I I really thought that it was blood
and so I scream I just like scream
because I feel this stuff I don't know
what it is I'm like scared and anxious
they flipped on the lights and these
[ __ ] had just put ketchup and mustard
all over me
they covered my entire body with ketchup
and mustard yeah like while I was
sleeping
they had like like everywhere and so
like I I'm embarrassed because I had
just woken up everyone in the room it
was a huge room I'm embarrassed this
woman had to like clean me up and like
I'm like I'm like why did they do this
why did they do this but then like I
just get like angry after that like I
went [ __ ] cold like I shut down as a
kid like I have been dealing with like
physical abuse like I was getting beat
up I was getting [ __ ] like yell that
I was getting spit on by these girls I
didn't know and then this was just like
it like this was last straw so this is
like where it gets weirder this is where
it gets even weirder David I can't
believe I'm telling this story there's
my shot this is very personal to me yeah
so so um this was this is a really
traumatizing event for me as a kid
because and and I I'm also okay with
telling this because as miniscule as it
seems I think it's important to remind
yourself of trauma and things that are a
shock to your system you know cuz this
really was because I felt betrayed by
you know my grandparents and my mom that
I'd made me go when I begged not to go I
did not want to go back to this place I
was fed up at this point I was
embarrassed I was hurt like everything
and like I went cold as like a seven or
eight year old child like I was [ __ ]
done yeah but um
so that happened on like a Friday or
Saturday night and my mom had to come
pick me up and like I could tell that
she was like really destroyed because um
she she wanted she wanted to make her
mom happy and my grandma my grandma was
very religious so my mom felt like she
had I had to go to this church I had to
be a Christian and my mom felt hurt
because she was like I can't believe I
[ __ ] let my child go like after you
know I had been seeing her come home
like upset from children's church every
day and um and so it was just kinda it
was like [ __ ] and so my mom like calls
like the pastor and is like what were
you guys watching
oh Jesus Christ what's up [ __ ] and
excuse me sorry in the name of Jesus
Christ are you [ __ ] kidding me yeah
and so like this is like a big deal and
like people in the church are talking
about it and [ __ ] - they're like oh oh
that's uh that's that's brother Percy's
kid yes you know there's like murmurs
and [ __ ] like that and then with my
prayers so we go to church on Sunday
this is where it gets [ __ ] weird so
we go to church on Sunday and it's a
black church you know any black folks
out there y'all ever been to a black
church you know this just like two hours
so at the end of the sermon entirely in
front of the entire congregation which
is like 200 people
the pastor calls up the three girls that
did this to me and asked them to come to
the front of the church calls in my name
and tells him to come up and he takes
this [ __ ] water and he goes I curse
you and your families I'm not [ __ ]
kidding David he's like your eyes just
went like what the [ __ ] - these like the
girl out of know pastors had that power
curse you I curse you and your families
this sounds like it's out of a [ __ ]
movie I swear on God this happened I
don't know if this guy thought that
doing this would make you feel better
yeah or my family feel better but
instead it was shaming the three girls
and all of their families who were in
the congregation and keep in mind it's
not just mom and dad going it's mom dad
brother sister on uncle so three girls
let's just multiply that by five fifteen
people in the congregation they've got
friends and friends to me as a child I
felt like everyone in that congregation
[ __ ] hated me
for being such a little [ __ ] you know
like and that was it that was the end of
the sermon he did that and he dismissed
everybody you know and I still had to go
to that church for a few years
damn what was that like after damn dude
that [ __ ] me up like it was I and you
know what the [ __ ] up thing is I don't
remember I was done I was completely
done with the world after that you know
and I mean like in that that wasn't the
only like unfortunate thing happened in
my life you know like there's there's
like a few just like small things that
basically the world told me very early
on before I was even 10 years old that
nobody wants you here yeah like that's
what I was told and that's and I saw the
world through a lens of that you know
yeah and it was yeah it was really rough
and like to be fair man I really can't
tell you because I don't I don't
remember I just blocked it out and it
took me it took me a long time to clean
my Sundays back yeah which I'm like
super happy to say I have them back now
for years I dreaded I hated Christmas
and I hated Sundays you hated Christmas
that's just a white dude with a beard I
was done I was I was because it meant it
just meant it just meant going back and
so like I would like as a kid I would
like you know Monday Tuesday Thursday
Friday psych was like cool and then
Saturday would hit and I knew Sunday was
going becoming and I had to go back to
the church so for like years and years
and years I was shut off to that you
know and and and you know and the other
thing is and like my mom's probably
gonna listen to [ __ ] we talked about it
like I don't really care
another thing is is that like it's it's
kind of that thing we talked about again
with the bubble my mom never she never
went through a depressed face like a
deprived like hating yourself phase so
she didn't know how deep my pain went
with this stuff could empathize she she
didn't understand you know and like it
was like a big deal for us like later on
in life to like come back and be like
you know like I forgive you and I didn't
understand you know it was really big
but I got my Sundays back I respect
Christianity now I can't have y'all
crazies running around but yes you know
you know a lot of people do have like
very traumatizing experiences like at
church and it's and it's kind of sad
because even for me to like I've had
those experiences yeah and like I had to
figure out for myself it's like well man
like I dude I remember uh there was it's
maybe it's because I think everything's
funny maybe okay well I'm gonna cry this
is hilarious this [ __ ] was [ __ ] crazy
man so I used to flip between two
different churches well three different
churches because my friends weren't
there so every now and then I would ask
my mom you can I spend the night on
Saturday at their house so I can go to
church with them my mom's like oh cool
but there was one church that I really
liked going to because I thought it was
such a [ __ ] up Church because some
[ __ ] would always happen so what Sunday
this dude so these two brothers known to
be hyper temperamental you're talking
about the stereotypical Korean angry
dudes these two dudes were [ __ ] name
DeSean and James not gonna say their
last names but they're Korean so you
could probably figure out what it is so
Sean and James right there's only a few
options these dudes were they played
rugby so already a very violent sport
but they were so [ __ ] angry right but
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened that
day at church wait help me I can't
remember me I had to be like this is
definitely I still was I was in the
junior high or like six sixth grade or
something like that so six seven thirty
something is something around there I
don't remember the exact age but you
want to talk about some savage [ __ ] so
so there's like a Korean joke they go
people say there's like let's me let's
make like a Korean Church and split just
because great churches split all the
[ __ ] time so this was a very pivotal
moment where this Baptist Church split
and it was due to be this one [ __ ]
fight this dude Sean and James's dad had
beef with a head pastor and this is
after the head pastor was done saying
his speech after he was doing his his
his whatever [ __ ] the it was and he was
kind of like within the sermon he was
kind of alluding to how we all have to
stick together like even though you have
differences and this is what God would
want and so he was kind of lightweight
throwing shade at the person that's
about to stand up and oppose him so he
basically said if anybody has anything
to say just come out in front of the
congregation let's talk about it so Sean
and James's dad who
I could tell who he got it their anger
problems from stood up and he was I and
that he just state goes up on the podium
with the pastor and starts cursing him
out in front of the whole [ __ ]
congregation I don't [ __ ] know I
don't know I don't really attend this
church and I'm like yeah what the [ __ ]
is going on he was [ __ ] his wife
something I don't know what it was right
I can get into some other stories about
that [ __ ] but I don't think that was the
case in this one I think like they just
didn't had disagreements about how how
the church was being ran and but this
guy was so [ __ ] temperament decided
to do it in front of the whole
congregation start cursing this time oh
my god dumb ass
Oh check this [ __ ] out right so
literally as they're going back and
forth they're screaming at each other
[ __ ] Sean and James these guys these
two dumb [ __ ] come up and they clock
the head pastor black socks the head
pastor I'm talking about an old [ __ ]
Korean man what just like defend their
dad and their dad was in no immediate
danger he's [ __ ] too scary like
roided-out [ __ ] meathead Korean dude X
the [ __ ] head pastor I'm so sad David
dude I was just like yo this is [ __ ]
WWF in real life I was like yo what the
[ __ ] is going on dude churches are
[ __ ] crazy do if you ever want I have
so many Church stories you people don't
even [ __ ] know you have cheating so I
got all you got [ __ ] to the church oh my
god can we like hit up like that weird I
was listening to a podcast today where
these girls were talking about how to
cheat and they look I'm gonna tell you
this [ __ ] this shit's crazy they were
like if you want to cheat go into your
notes section on iPhone and then share
it with the girl that you're talking to
what the [ __ ] that's amazing because
they were like your girlfriend will
never find it so I'm saying that people
are just like and also I was like I was
eight these are women all is like are
you [ __ ] really telling them how did
it we're supposed to be in this together
yeah
where's most meetings yeah people don't
[ __ ] know man like I got so much the
reason why I don't even tell half of
these like bad Church stories is because
to me it's an entertainment but I don't
want to deter people from Christian
that's parties that like it's fun to me
it's funny though like I look at it as
this is hilarious because you know as I
say churches for the the sick and the
hurt so they're not there's not supposed
to be perfect human beings at church so
suppose also I think it's safe to say
that like let's just say 70% of churches
have good intentions 30% don't yeah and
there and we I think we can all agree
that there are some that are like oh I'm
I'm a believable person I'm a [ __ ]
sociopath and I want to make some money
I'm gonna open a church it's not it's
nonprofit like that da da da da and got
some stuff well [ __ ] man we actually hit
an hour so yeah that's tight though we
went into some deep [ __ ] we did that's
what happen to get a little sake no I
mean I barely even touched that [ __ ] you
know but like what like about like
halfway through I opened my mouth I was
like I can't believe I'm giving David
this content for free you know what the
crazy think about the in it is you could
tell that same story in your own
personal space it'll be ten times better
it's just different you know any because
I've told I've told the same stories
like on JK news and I have on this
podcast but it comes off different every
time when you do it on your own plan
yeah because you're allowed to elaborate
in a way that you can't when you're put
on the spot
David so much fucked-up [ __ ] has
happened to me that like a ketchup and
mustard is like I feel like it's like
actually no that was bad because I was
like a child that's pretty bad it was
like night especially at a safe place
especially at an area where you had a
conversation with your mom and your
grandma you said I don't feel safe there
and they sent you there anyways so if
you guys don't know what a lock lock
lock it is that's what it is thank you
so you know you've kind of felt betrayed
by everybody's like who do I have to
turn to cuz I told you I didn't want to
go that you sent me there anyways I go
there and now the situation became worse
it's hard because like you know
especially for your mom too because it's
a church she always thinks that the
church has the best intentions yeah and
I believe that the religion has best
intentions but not people and you can't
control every single person exactly but
you know we you know we won't keep
rolling on yeah okay [ __ ] anyways well
just to clarify what a lock-in is if you
guys don't know a lock a lot of churches
had this [ __ ] where a bunch of the kids
will stay in at the churches see I have
a big sleepover at night they do like
Bible study and prays and they spend the
night and have a slumber party that's
what that [ __ ] is it's not some [ __ ]
prison [ __ ] like
that'll be a lockdown anyways you guys
catches on Spotify you could catch us on
[ __ ] what's that iTunes whatever
audio platform that is but remember if
you guys see us leave comments leave
comment below about who you want to be
on here topics that we should talk about
current events whatever we're gonna get
in on that [ __ ] bows where can they find
you what do you want to plug on
Instagram oh and yeah
that's yes instagram my instagram is big
boss bows find me there and we have
another project coming out some of the
JK news girls this june you'll find
links to it there when it gets announced
it's gonna be some crazy [ __ ] like I'm
telling you I definitely won't be a
guest on there but I will say this yeah
if I ever do I cannot [ __ ] wait I
love Girl Talk oh God
alright Joe see y'all next time